le jour où tu es parti pour marseille
j'ai conduit à l'aéroport
je suis allé à la boutique de cadeaux et j'ai vu ce
collier c'était de l'or dit de l'eau plate dessus
j'ai pensé que ce serait
un petit morceau de maison à emporter avec toi
[Musique]
des gens  sont nés
tu es dans mes yeux pour l'occasion
oh ce n'est pas ma fille
ouais le père de la fille l'étudiante américaine
oui madame
allison est venue ici pour l'université et c'est
là qu'elle a rencontré cette fille lina
une nuit elle a trouvé lena morte et  appelé
la police
tout ce qui les intéressait était qu'alison couchait
avec une fille arabe
je l'aimais je sais que tu l'as fait mais tout le monde
pense que je l'ai tuée
nous avons épuisé toutes les
actions en justice possibles c'est qu'un avocat ne t'aide pas
je le fais moi-même pour l'instant  je pourrais avoir
comment tu
t'appelles william maya c'est gentil
elle est très protectrice avec moi
tu as vu ce gars avant que
personne ne te parle fais moi confiance
et pas d'ici
ce n'est pas sûr pour toi
c'est ma petite fille dieu
s'il
te plait je ne vais pas abandonner
ce serait une grave erreur de  commettez un
crime pour prouver que votre fille est innocente cela
ne la fera pas sortir de prison
et cela vous enverra dans le
seigneur s'il vous plaît gardez un œil vigilant sur
alison amen
police lui avez-vous demandé de mentir j'essaie de
faire sortir ma petite fille de prison  c'est
tout ce que je me fous de toi sembler très
américain en ce moment bon je le suis ouais et
tu es aussi un étranger ici
qu'as-tu fait tu dois
juste me faire confiance